hey guys Ryan right over here I'm going
to be checking out the trailer today for
the gift don't know anything about it
it's Jason Statham here we go
did I just say Jason Statham I meant
Jason Bateman I'll go to gift I could be
good for long son yes yes you we went to
school together this is my wife Robin
this is Gordon Moseley Gordo Gordo oh my
god so sorry to recognize it it's been a
very very long time
come home smiley face Gordo thank you
I believe that the bad things seem like
they can be a gift because odd he's a
real especially awkward and I can be
like that after high school and some
people's taste that for this he's
delusional
thanks to poor friends loves it dinner
food you don't find that a little
trouble except that I want it fish and
all the visits when you're alone they
just call me Gordo the weirdo I think
he's nice and he's been very generous
what you're talking about is a one-sided
friendship you're essentially being
forced into a breakup there's no easy
way to say this don't visit us anymore
Simon after all these years I was
willing to let bygones be bygones I do
not know
it must mean something bigger than
speech oh I think he's been lying to you
just tell me what that was 25 years ago
no idea you believe
Simon Says
new house
Simon Says you like Simon Says
a stick you're done with the past but
the past is not that one yet I really
want to see that movie there's so many
reasons to check it out
Jason Bateman yeah you know he has a
regular personality at first he's the
Jason Bateman we all know you know the
sarcasm the dry sincerity it's clearly
gonna take a different turn for his
character when all this [ __ ] starts
going down you know just seeing him
having that emotional crime scene it's a
blue Mouse production or blum house or
I'm not going to vote cab you there and
I'm sorry but they do a lot of horror
films this looks more like a
psychological thriller than a
straightforward horror flick and I'm
very intrigued by it I want to see Jason
Bateman's performance I really like joel
edgerton rebecca hall is a wonderful
actress you got three great actors and a
psychological thriller dealing with
obsession you need great actors to pull
off something like this and it's bloom
house they're really good with doing
suspense and it's been a while since we
got a really good obsessive thriller the
characters all look like they have life
I'm interested to see what Jason
Bateman's dark past is I'm really hooked
by this this looks pretty [ __ ]
awesome actually I want to know what the
gift is it's a dick in a box
dick in a box anyway guys thanks for
checking out my video today if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter need
more followers because I am trying to
convert as many people to Christianity
as possible the way of the Lord praise
be to God that's Catholicism Hunter M
hunter highwayman hey man I'm a huge
fees at Hwy I'm a huge fan if you could
please give me a shout-out not trying to
get viewers for subs or anything I just
want to shout out from my own personal
preference isn't how to spell very well
you know sorry about that I can't figure
out how to spell those words what I mean
is just for me but I got off track I do
that a lot thanks for being great people
and you all are so funny
keep it going and I love
y'all hugs to the man and kisses to the
girls hunter em thank you so much man
what if you're a total [ __ ] hunter you
get it such a badass name don't be a
[ __ ] whatever happens you must never be
a [ __ ] you can eat [ __ ] and you can
[ __ ] [ __ ] but never become a [ __ ] you
got a lot to live up to with that name
son